Progressive Portland is finally cracking
down on rampant homelessness that has
plagued the city for years it only took
a reported 50 percent increase in the
problem for them to finally do something
about it and crazy scenes like this
where a family got terrorized by a group
of squatters next door who almost set
their house on fire Democrat mayor Ted
wheeler is calling for a daytime ban on
camps and fires on public property and
wants to restrict camping near schools
and more than a dozen other locations
repeat offenders could face fines and
even jail time the mayor's spelling out
the problem
there are currently hundreds of
unsanctioned sometimes dangerous and
often Squall in homeless camps across
the 146 square miles of Portland these
homeless camps represent nothing short
of a humanitarian catastrophe
as a result our community continues to
suffer substantial public health safety
and livability concerns my goal is to
have enough shelter housing and
treatment access available so that we
can fully eliminate unsanctioned
unsheltered camping in the city of
Portland
in legendary singer-songwriter John
Mellencamp is releasing a song about
Portland's homeless crisis where he
slammed City officials for destroying
one of his favorite places
as I saw through the edge
[Music]
during the day as not to be on when some
went away
Rachel I don't know if you're a
Mellencamp fan or not that's John
Mellencamp that video is actually I
guess footage from LA and and they're
responding saying you didn't even it's
not even Portland really that's in the
video it's like well all you're pointing
out is that other liberal run cities
have the same kind of problem yeah but
as a political spouse it's always
something you make sure that the footage
you're using that your husband's using
his commercials from the place you say
it's from
um listen the situation is so bad that
they think that one of the only things
that's actually making this action
happen on the part of the government to
correct this down is a lawsuit from
disabled people because they can't even
get on the through the sidewalks
um the homeless problem is ultimately a
drug problem and the drug problem is a
border problem and so all of these
issues Joey are Democrat issues now how
do you solve it I mean we need we need
more drug rehab we need to control the
border so that we don't have these drugs
on the street and when I look at those
images we clearly it's it's a drug
problem it's a spiritual problem there's
a lot of things going on our country is
is going through a lot Jessica's going
to go to you later but you know she says
hey it's a Democrat problem because of
the policies the Democrats put forth
um there's a literally a ninth Circuit
Court ruling the most liberal Circuit
Court saying that hey you can't penalize
people for being homeless and then on
top of that Oregon comes in and passes a
bill that says you can't stop people
from what they call keep warm and dry
which basically means you can't stop
them from doing what they're doing in
most places
well first to the it's just a Democrat
problem we've had a drug problem in this
country for decades the War on Drugs is
not ours right that was started under
another kind of administration and it
continues and it's pervasive and we have
a fentanyl problem and we know that 90
of the fentanyl that gets trafficked
into the countries coming across by
Americans themselves that are taking it
in and a lot of regular ports of entry
and that's why we're confiscating so
much of it so I I reject that
explanation for it but this is one of
the more heartbreaking things my family
spends a lot of time in Portland
um it is obviously not what it used to
be
um I think that's important to draw
attention to this but the fundamental
question that people have to ask
themselves and that I certainly ask
myself is what is actually the thing
that you need to do to help these people
right have we everyone want most people
I would say want to treat people with
respect and with dignity and for them to
be able to have a better life and what
is the correct way to be able to get to
that end goal and it used to be I
remember when Bloomberg was mayor here
in New York there was a shelter bed for
every single homeless person in this
city and on really cold nights you
couldn't find people on the street
that's not the case anymore and that's
not necessarily because there aren't
beds available people are choosing it
whether they're mentally ill whether
they're on drugs strung out whatever it
is and we need to make sure in cities
like Portland there are enough beds for
everyone but that you treat the root
cause of why people are choosing this
kind of Lifestyle in some cases not not
in all of them rather than going inside
or getting into treatment program and
assisted housing and getting back on
their feet well Tyrus just in Portland
specifically it looks like is there a
politician more inept at their job than
Ted wheeler just doing the research here
they've spent billions of dollars the
problem is 50 percent worse and this is
his answer find homeless people 100 or
30 days in jail yeah okay uh let's just
stop then he goes back and says well we
might find other ways to punish them
well this was your Progressive socialist
idea you you decimate the police force
you give everybody tents you give
everybody needles needles lighters
whatever they need for their substance
because this is the Utopia that you
wanted here's the side effect of it now
it's become a huge problem but you were
the root cause of it with your policies
you have made places like Portland a
beacon for homeless you can come here
you can have you can do whatever you
want you can have whatever you want so
now they're all there and they have
tents and again if you look at the thing
it says daytime fires now listen I'm I'm
not a rock Insurgent but most of my
fires would probably be at night when
I'm cold so during the day if I'm going
to make s'mores or something I want to
make a fire during the day that's an
easy way and more way to put things out
you see a fire hey you can't do that
during the day okay so but at night when
the fires are going then what are you
going to do right you know it's again
it's the same thing they're trying to
put like oh this is a human no this is
poor politics this is poor politicians
making first worlders making decisions
that they have no experience in dealing
with they're not helping they're causing
problems and now it's a huge problem but
it's not the homeless's fault you put
them in this position you gave them
these things and now oh somebody it now
it's a problem because why it's
affecting him it's affecting his bottom
line his voters are complaining his
donors are complaining right so now if
they weren't he wouldn't it would be the
same thing we see it in all these like
there was things were tense and they
make their little cities and that's what
they're going to do if that's what
you're getting well and on that on that
point Shannon we talk about did you ask
for this problem did you vote for this
problem did you enact this problem when
we talk about legislation Oregon had a
right to rest build it would have
compensated people up to a thousand
dollars for having to be homeless that
failed but we look at the bill that did
pass this keep warm and dry Bill and
what you have is the state legislature
by working off of what the night circuit
said almost took away Ted willer's
ability to do anything about this to
begin with can I just say I'm so
impressed by your knowledge of the ninth
circuit
yeah these these are not they should not
be unexpected consequences of what we've
told people when we have cities that are
fighting to pass areas where you can
shoot up and they will have people
standing by to save your life if you do
this if we're legalizing all kinds of
things people will talk about compassion
we want people I agree with you Jessica
I think 99.9 of people their heartbreaks
when they see people in this condition
because they seem very helpless and
overwhelmed and like they nobody wants
this kind of life
um but it's not compassionate to tell
people that there's going to be no law
enforcement we're going to allow you to
live in these horrible conditions we are
going to allow you to shoot up drugs
that are killing you or whether it's a
mental health issue because so many of
these cases are that as well we all live
and work in New York I live in DC I walk
by groups of homeless people all the
time who do not look well and my heart
breaks for them but if you have
Progressive policies that reward that
behavior like Tyra said you can't expect
it's not going to happen and I don't
think sometimes
but it's always in the name of Freedom
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else